hoch hinaus die Schweiz über 3000 Metern
wird präsentiert von Bächli Bergsport
wir leben Bergsport
[Musik]
Mitte Juli am Matterhorn die Touristen
strömen hinauf zur hörnlehütte
um dem Berg nahezukommen
in diesem hitze-sommer ist das
Matterhorn so ausgearbeitet wie sonst
nie das birgt Gefahren für die
Bergsteiger
in der Hörnlihütte kontrolliert das
Hüttenwart Ehepaar die Situation am Berg
hier übernachtet wer aufs Matterhorn
will
[Musik]
dies ist die Geschichte des ersten
hitzewochenendes in diesem Sommer auf
der hörnlehütte am Matterhorn
Hüttenwartin edith hat ein Problem
aber natürlich Lösungen
ein Koch ist auf der Hörnlihütte
kurzfristig abgesprungen und das
ausgerechnet am ersten
sommerferienwochenende
das Ehepaar Edith und Martin Lena führt
die Hütte seit 4 Jahren
ist eigentlich gelernte Pflegefachfrau
sensationell
die Hörnlihütte ist ein wander Hotspot
in Zermatt
aber die Tagestourismus
es ist Vormittag und noch ist es ruhig
darum hat Martin Lena Zeit und etwas zu
zeigen worauf er stolz ist
neue the matterhornist
angefangen am
wiederhole ich im Sommer
das Familienwelt
[Musik]
250 Franken kostete damals die
Besteigung des Matterhorns mit Führer
heute sind es über 1.500 Franken Martin
ist wie sein Vater auch Bergführer
sehr viel los und noch ist natürlich für
mich hat es zwei Punkte sind
für mich ist natürlich
für mich das
Sommerberg für die ist für mich nachher
mit gestorben und das ist schon eine
strikte
jetzt haben wir so belegt ob ich jetzt
das wirklich will oder nicht
[Musik]
der hüttenstress beginnt die Hörnlihütte
lebt von der Nähe zum Matterhorn
[Musik]
direkt hinter der Hütte beginnt die
Kletterei
bei uns steht das Matterhorn in
Disneyland südkalifornia träumen davon
das richtige Matterhorn zu besteigen
bis zu 150 Gäste müssen über Mittag
verpflegt werden der einzig verbliebene
Koch Freddy und sein Helfer Peter sind
gefordert
7 Mitarbeitende hat die Chefin
zusammen ist es machbar alleine
die Hörnlihütte hat nicht nur viele
Tagesgäste sondern auch noch 150 Betten
zum übernachten in diesen heißen Tagen
sorgt sich Martin um die
Wasserversorgung
das Schmelzwasser der umliegenden
Gletscher ist die einzige Wasserquelle
an schönen Tagen verbraucht die Hütte
fast 6000 Liter Wasser das hochgepumpt
wird ein großer Teil davon die
WC-Spülung Martin ist für alles
verantwortlich
Mensch
und normalerweise im Schnee wo wir hier
oben in der City
aber wenn das 24 Stunden läuft
eigentlich ist Martin gelernter
Schreiner muss nun aber auch die Technik
im Griff haben
die ganze Batterie der Generator und die
batteriellader
[Musik]
die jüngste Tochter Debbie kommt für das
Wochenende aus dem Tal hoch hallo
Lenas leben eigentlich in Zermatt die
drei Kinder kommen oft hoch um zu helfen
martin hat seit Tagen starke
Rückenschmerzen edith hat Medikamente
organisiert
[Musik]
es ist inzwischen halb fünf Uhr abends
die Bergführer kommen hoch für die Tour
aufs Matterhorn am nächsten Tag Dennis
gruber ist Zermatter Bergführer und viel
hier oben
[Musik]
die Bergführer erfahren oft erst am
Abend vorher wen sie aufs Matterhorn
führen
aber
meistens Vorbereitung
viele Bergführer bringen Geschenke aus
dem Tal und das ist wirklich
Kavalier ist da bringt es immer
schneeblume
die Hörnlihütte gehört der
Burgergemeinde Zermatt darum haben die
Einheimischen Bergführer in der Hütte
ihr eigenes Zimmer
am schlafen
geschlafen
sehr trocken Moment und das der Vorteil
ist man muss weniger
Schnee draußen
Dennis trifft zum ersten Mal seine Gäste
die er und ein Kollege aufs Matterhorn
führen werden es sind zwei Franzosen aus
Straßburg
tipptopp
seid ihr in Form
ja und bereit
wir hoffen mit ihm auf den Gipfel zu
kommen
am Matterhorn hat jeder Führer nur einen
Gast am Seil ein Kollege von Dennis wird
am Abend dazu stoßen
unbedingt
[Gelächter]
Martin informiert die Bergführer jeden
Abend über die Verhältnisse am Berg ich
rede auf Walliserdeutsch
und nachher französischen noch mal
englisch
bitte kommt nicht vorher herunter also
in den Frühstücksraum und am zehn vor
vier
ist der Morgen Turbo der lidguide
einfach nicht vorher losgehen bevor das
nicht der Seilbahn macht und los geht
die Verhältnisse am Berg sind eigentlich
sehr gut so wie die Kameraden heute die
zurückgekommen sind erzählt haben
natürlich hat dieses Jahr nicht gerade
viel Schnee mehr aber schauen dass sie
vielleicht beim Hochgehen haben wir
gestern gesagt um kurzen Seil geht und
dann am runtergehen müsst ihr dann
schauen wir irgendwas geht und dann das
müsst ihr selber entscheiden
es ist Hochsaison trotzdem sind wenig
Leute am Berg ob das damit zu tun hat
dass an vielen Orten in den Alpen schon
über die Steinschlag Gefahr diskutiert
wird
kommuniziert das Smartphone
zum Beispiel momentan kommuniziert wird
vom montblances
Hotels diese Probleme hätte das Tüte zu
stecken immer fast leistet sind er wird
hier natürlich muss ich sagen
[Musik]
auch Vater Andreas wenn morgen mit
seinem 14-jährigen Sohn Linus aufs
Matterhorn der Oberschule
das Matterhorn ist nicht zu
unterschätzen hier gibt es mehr
Todesfälle als an jedem anderen
Schweizer Berg
diese Bergsteiger waren heute 14 Stunden
lang unterwegs zwei italienische
Studenten
der Abstieg war furchtbar
es ist viel einfacher hoch als
runterzugehen
man kommt schnell von der Route ab
wir haben uns zweimal im Abstieg
verstiegen und jedes Mal hat uns das
eineinhalb Stunden gekostet
das hüttenpaar verfolgt was am Berg
passiert
ihr wart auf der Matterhorn ja und was
ist jetzt euer Plan nach Hause gehen
in der Hütte zur übernachten kommt für
sie nicht in Frage
150 Euro pro Nacht sind ganz schön viel
wir können uns das nicht leisten
die neue Hütte ist tatsächlich fast
doppelt so teuer wie früher und
campieren ist jetzt verboten ihnen
bleibt nur der fünfstündige Abstieg nach
Zermatt da die Bahn nicht mehr fährt
[Musik]
der Tag neigt sich dem Ende zu doch
Martins rückenschmerzen müssen noch
behandelt werden
[Musik]
um 9 Uhr gehen die meisten Bergsteiger
schon ins Bett
alles ist ruhig doch um 10:15 Uhr ein
spätankömmling aufgebrochen heute morgen
in Mailand hallo was machst du denn hier
überleben
wo kommst du her ich habe die letzte
Bahn am Schwarzsee verpasst hast du eine
Reservation ja mein Name ist Moises
Martinez
gehst du morgen aufs Matterhorn wenn es
geht würde ich noch eine Zusatznacht
buchen und morgen Pause machen
gehst du alleine aufs Matterhorn
ja alleine
du bist in Zimmer 23 alleine denn alle
anderen schlafen bereits
der Koch ist schon seit vielen Stunden
auf den Beinen trotzdem macht er sich
nochmals an die Arbeit
zwei Nächte ruhen und dann aufs
Matterhorn dies der Plan von Moises
[Musik]
tagwacht für die Hütten Crew
Frühstückszeit für die Bergsteiger heute
[Musik]
ja eigentlich
also ich benutzen
sie erstmals
20 nach drei der zermatterbergführer
dennis ist einer der ersten der
herunterkommt in der neuen Hütte gilt
ein strikter Zeitplan
Vater Andreas und Sohn Linus sind auch
wach
[Musik]
niemand darf starten bevor der liedguide
Turbo um viertel vor vier vom Tisch
aufsteht
zuerst starten die Einheimischen
Bergführer dann die auswärtigen zuletzt
diejenigen ohne Führer
[Musik]
um zehn vor vier ist es soweit mach es
gut
an zweiter Stelle Dennis mit einem
Franzosen
te
jetzt kommt der Papa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
direkt hinter der Hütte ist der steile
Einstieg
86 Bergsteiger sind heute gestartet
manchmal sind es über 100
[Musik]
etwa acht Stunden wird die Tour für
Vater und Sohn dauern
[Musik]
nur wenige gehen ohne Bergführer hallo
ich bin alleine da hinten ist noch
jemand alleine
was ist der
Plane gehe ich auf den Gipfel wenn nicht
Kehre
[Musik]
zwei Stunden später eigentlich hätte
Martin Edith jetzt ablösen sollen
nein telefonieren
[Musik]
um halb acht ist der versorgungsflug der
erdzermatt angekündigt
das ganze mit dem Wasser mit dem
Generator und dann macht und dadurch
650 Kilogramm Getränke und Essen
Eier vorsichtig
jeden zweiten Tag gibt es einen
versorgungsflug
Muskelkater
wenig Zeit um die Hütte zu putzen
mäuses der spätankömmling ist wach guten
Morgen
die neue Hörnlihütte ist mehr ein Hotel
als eine Berghütte dazu gehören duschen
und WCs mit fließendem Wasser in über
3000 Metern Höhe
[Applaus]
und hopp
die Teppich
[Musik]
Martin der Bergführer immer wenn er Zeit
hat gilt sein Blick dem Berg es ist erst
halb zehn und schon kommen die ersten
Bergsteiger zurück eigentlich ist es
viel zu früh es ist Dennis mit seinem
französischen Gast
Kaffee
weit oben auf über 4000 Metern sind die
ersten Bergsteiger im Gipfelbereich
sichtbar in anderen Jahren war das
Matterhorn jeweils um diese Jahreszeit
noch voller Schnee jetzt hat es wegen
der Trockenheit und Hitze viel Geröll
dass ich auch manchmal löst
das macht Danny Sorgen der das Problem
sind doch das heißt also wenn
und eine fixe Seilen dass man da immer
drunter ist sicheres Problem aber das
müssen wir uns jeden Tag mit Beobachter
und aber wenn man das gesehen immer mit
anderen informieren
der Berg steht schon länger unter
Beobachtung nach einem großen
felsausbruch im letzten Hitzesommer 2003
schauen Martin
Beutel ist regelmäßig bei Martin in der
hörnlehütte er ist Wissenschaftler und
misst seit dem Ausbruch die Bewegung am
Berg
herzlich willkommen
Jan Beutel will heute einen Sensor für
seine Messungen auswechseln direkt unter
der Hörnlihütte seit über 15 Jahren
sammelt er
live-abbruch hoffentlich vorhersagen zu
können
was ist das jetzt
das ist ein drahtlossensor für unsere
Messstellen oben
und das ist jetzt nur ein Wireless relay
dass wir hin und her Funken und da muss
eine neue Batterie rein
auch ihn beunruhigt die derzeitige Hitze
denn wenn der Permafrost auftaut sprengt
der Wasserdruck den Fels
sie wissen es hier unten in der
Hörnlihütte
wir haben natürlich auch die Daten auf
der Wetterstation und da sehen wir
natürlich ganz extrem wie die letzte
Woche immer wärmer wird
die vorletzte Nacht und die letzte Nacht
waren plus gerade auf 4000 Meter und das
ist extrem ungewöhnlich das ist Stress
für den Berg das ist Stress pur ja also
das wenn wenn nicht mal in der Nacht das
noch mal runterkühlen kann wenn es
wolkenlos ist dann heißt es dass es
wirklich den Berg aufheizt und das geht
in die Tiefe und mit einer ziemlich
großen Verzögerung kommt diese Wärme in
der Tiefe an und taugt dort immer mehr
den gefrorenen Fels auf
und ja da kann es dann natürlich schon
zu Instabilitäten kommen
auftauender tiefer Permafrost ist eine
Gefahr
fehlendes Eis an der Oberfläche die
andere wenn kein Eis mehr die
geröllschichten bedeckt steigt die
Steinschlag Gefahr ausgelöst durch die
Bergsteiger
Martin erkundigt sich bei den Kollegen
jeden Tag wie es aussieht speziell am
Gipfel
das ist das Problem
Informationen verwenden
wird somit für die nächsten Tage vorerst
keine Warnung für die Bergsteiger
aussprechen nicht mehr aufs Matterhorn
zu gehen
Samstagmittag Bergführer David Fasel ist
mit den Frauen zurück vom Berg
ich einfach öfter
auch der zweite Franzose kommt an
es war hart
aber wir haben es geschafft
der Abstieg war härter als der Aufstieg
die Beine die Knie
man muss sich wirklich gut vorbereiten
sonst geht es nicht
[Musik]
nach gut zehn Stunden tauchen auch der
14-Jährige Linus und sein Vater auf
[Musik]
gratuliere
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
es wird Abend in der Hütte
doch es gibt ein Problem
anscheinend sind es zwei Iraner die
draußen die Nacht verbringen wollen
zwei drei Stunden danach losfahren weil
ich dir eben nicht schlafen ja
ich weiß ganz sicher
weil sonst wenn ihr hier geht geht das
ins Wasser und dann ist das Wasser in
der hörnlehütte
ja als Trinkwasser dann ist das also es
kommt ja in die Gletscher rein und dann
kommt das in die Hütte und das ist eben
das der Grund wieso das Campen hier oben
eigentlich verboten ist wir wollen nicht
böse oder so
wir wollen nur sagen weil wenn ihr hier
bleibt dann müsst ihr Geld bezahlen dann
gibt es dann eine Busse wenn ich hier
schlafen bedanken wir uns für die Info
und wir machen gleich
am nächsten Tag wieder ruft der Berg
Heimer
ciao ciao
[Musik]
und weg
wieder ein heißer Tag mit plus
Temperaturen bis fast 5000 Meter
[Musik]
auch Jan denn Wissenschaftler zieht es
heute ans Matterhorn zu dem
Bewegungssensoren am hörnligrat dorthin
wo im letzten Hitzesommer der
Felsabbruch war
noch ist der Berg ruhig Entwarnung gibt
der Wissenschaftler aber nicht also wenn
es jetzt wirklich ganz ganz große und
starke schnelle Niederschläge hat und
das jeden Tag oder vielleicht auch
Dauerregen dann haben wir schon ein
Problem weil das Wasser wird dann
natürlich wenn es auf den warmen fällst
trifft in der Tiefe noch mal viel mehr
Eis Schmelz
Martin Lena kontrolliert auch heute
seine Wasserfassung diesmal von weiter
unten
aber das hoffe das ist dieser Sommer
jetzt noch einigermaßen im Wasser Guide
aber
viel Wasser
seine Frau Edith wird die nächsten Tage
nochmals gefordert sein
gut die Möglichkeit
Freddy der einzige Koch macht drei Tage
frei Edith und Küchenhilfe Peter müssen
übernehmen
und Tschüss
das erste sommerferienwochenende ist
überstanden Lenas haben kurz Zeit für
einen schwarz mit Bekannten treffen
alle Bergsteiger sind zurück in der
Hütte nur einer fehlt noch der
Einzelgänger mäuses
alleine ohne Bergführer ist da heute
morgen tatsächlich zum Matterhorn
aufgebrochen nun muss er von
Bergsteigern zurück in die Hütte
eskortiert werden
den Gipfel hat er nicht erreicht
er war gerade da drüben am Wandfuß
Richtung Schnee
du hast dich verlaufen ja zwei
Schutzengel
ich habe mich verlaufen gedacht es geht
da drüben hinunter
hat er um Hilfe gerufen
was gefährlich ja er stand direkt über
einer steilen Felswand und hat es von
oben nicht bemerkt wir riefen ihm zu
nicht weiterzugehen sonst wäre es sehr
gefährlich geworden ein Wunder dass er
bis hierher gekommen ist ja
zum Glück habe ich sie getroffen sonst
hätte ich die Rettung gerufen
trinke viel
dann gehst du noch runter ich habe die
Bahn verpasst ja die letzte warum fünf
funktioniert die Lampe noch
du wirst sie brauchen
und jetzt mit den rastkraft oder
eine Woche später hat ein anderer
Einzelgänger weniger Glück er rutscht
auf einer Felsplatte aus und stürzt
tödlich ab
[Musik]
für Information breakfast
please don't come down before
was die Hütten Crew noch nicht weiß der
Wanderweg wird vorübergehend gesperrt
werden müssen weil Geröll herunterkommt
und das Matterhorn wird bald komplett
schneefrei sein und von den
einheimischen Führern zwei Wochen lang
nicht bestiegen werden es ist ihnen zu
gefährlich
[Musik]